les bureaux de la rs c'est ici que l'on
prend la décision d'interdire ou pas la
baignade en mer et à sainte-anne elle a
été interdite à cause d'une pollution
fécale qui s'accompagne de bactéries et
de virus qui eux peuvent donner des
petits problèmes sanitaires du style
problème de toute la sphère orl donc des
problèmes de dos tite des problèmes naso
pharyngé des des conjonctivites des
choses comme ça voire voir des des
gastro entérites la plage des salines ce
matin côté table du diable le personnel
municipal met en place une affiche un
arrêté interdisant la baignade du cap
chevalier aux salines pour cause de
pollution
un arrêté qui stipule que tout
contrevenant sera poursuivie par la loi
et pendant l'installation du panneau des
campeurs qu'ils ne déménagent non point
à cause de la qualité de l'eau mais à
cause de la tempête d'orient et ce
campeur a son idée sur cette pollution
brenda et maman 1.212 à 10 fois par des
boulettes qu'à caler tout plagiat est il
des mouches à l'oeil grafite et au
géographe et footing des plus hauts
magistrats aux sables-d'olonne des
matières fécales sur la plage qui
viendraient de la mer et pas du camping
c'est une hypothèse
et du côté du bourg de sainte-anne on
évoque d'autres pistes premièrement à
cette période de l'année il n'y a pas de
courant aux salines l'eau ne se
renouvelle pas ces deux grands pas le
mois de septembre
la mère elle est camille a pas de vent
il n'y a pas de courants ses célèbres
pas fan non les marins pêcheurs
on va on va pêcher du poisson roses et
des graviers on prend des boissons c'est
parce qu'il n'ya pas droit
et pendant notre interview de plaisance
yens aux portes d'un bout de corail il
nous explique que les voiliers arrache
les coraux avec leur encre et qu'il
pollue aussi avec des matières fécales
normalement à chaque bateau il devrait
avoir ce qu'on appelle un bac à graisse
un bac à graisse est pour mais tout ce
qui tout ce qui est matières fécales
tout ce qui
liquide à remettre en gros je dirais
comme chez nous dans une fosse septique
et ceci quand il est plein ces personnes
là doivent automatiquement le vide est à
terre ya justement au sol ce qu'on
appelle d un dévidoir sauf que ce type
de vidange n'existe pas à sainte anne
méaux marin suivant une procédure
particulière avec l'arrivée du mauvais
temps la pollution devrait s'en aller
mais cela ne devrait pas régler le
problème de son origine